Okay. So today I'm cutting bangs on my own,
not a hairstylist. Here we go.
I'm only doing this because my sister did it and it looked really cute,
except she has a completely different face shape than me and I'm bored are
right. I don't really even have the tools,
dull scissors and potentially pretty good scissors,
but they haven't been used in forever. So I found a knife sharpener.
Ooh.
You've been sounded good.
No idea what I'm doing kind of briefly saw people doing this, really?
Just kind of going for it. There we go. Only really shouldn't do this. Okay.
But, you know, screw it very demanding.
I don't have a comb. I only have this comb really not the right comb,
but it's fine. I'll I'll use the end of this. Okay. So, um,
thank you. Do a triangle from here. Okay.
I think that's kind of.
The vibe. I dunno. Let's start less. And then we'll go to more actually,
let me bring this down here. Okay. Oh my God.
It's so much hair for like, I have then hair, but that's a lot of strands.
I can do this. I can do this.
I don't even know.
Purpose. You want to make sure that's all,
even it's all baby hairs on the side.
I have more baby hairs on this side than I do on this side.
The trick is to keep it. Apparently this is terrifying.
I never had bangs in my life. Today's the day. Oh, I'm so nervous.
And why do nerves kick in? It's so weird. It's just bangs, like chill,
go down and then I turn and then I take
this and I turn again. That doesn't feel right. All right. Let me do that again.
Why is this so scary?
So straight down at the bridge of the nose turn and then you grab it
and then you turn to get, no, it looks messy. I'm going to do it one more time.
Okay. Why am I shaking? Oh my God. Get out of your comfort zone.
Not comfortable at all. Okay.
Oh, it's already been done. Okay. Oh my God.
Oh my God. Oh my God.
Oh my God.
Oh.
I'm not at the bridge of my nose. I did everything.
Wrong, but I can't see if I'm cutting here.
Well, the hairstylists are watching this being like, Oh girl, you done up.
That's uneven. Well, okay. Maybe I'll use my mirror.
Oh my God.
Oh no. Oh no.
Oh, this is, Oh, this is Oh,
okay. I mean, actually don't I don't hate it.
A little uneven already. Pretty short. Thank God. I didn't go shorter.
Definitely a diagonal line going on on the one side. Okay.
I feel like I can fix this. I feel like I've never had bangs in my life.
I've never had bangs in my life. Oh, this is weird. Oh, where's all my hair.
There it is.
Nobody has.
Why is this side so much longer?
Why something's happening? I'm not sure what this side is getting longer.
Maybe if I reversed the twist.
Well.
Gotcha. The hope. Why? Why? Why are you doing that to me?
Okay. I know Foucault.
I didn't tell anybody I was doing this.
I didn't even tell Falco I was doing this. Oh, that's okay. Okay. So let me,
let me just, let me start like this.
It looks like I just have a little colic there. I don't even have a strainer.
Okay. Let's see. Wala. There we go.
Looks great. Oh. This is hot. I think it's too long.
I think we have to go shorter. I mean, it's kind of cool.
Definitely needs to be actually, I don't know. I kinda like it,
but it's always going to be in my eyes. It's too long. Right. Anybody can do it.
You can do it. You know, I also heard about doing this
to make it more like airy and light, I guess. You know? I think I fixed it.
I think I did this. I can do this. If you want bangs, you get them bangs.
What do you think so far?
[Inaudible].
Oh, now I see the problem. It's just,
I don't have enough hair on the other side,
but I'm not hating it harder to see, but I'm not hating it. All right.
And there's the look.
[Inaudible].
Do you have a new personality now? Yes. My changed woman. Yes. Am I proud?
Yes. Do I trust myself? Apparently. Do I recommend this?
Yes I do. I'm very proud. Yo, you come here.
Come here.
I cut beings. Come here.
Is.
That a wig?
Is it a wig? My dog mom. Now.
Are they too long idea? Do you like.
It or is it not good? It looks good. It's just so different. But it looks good.
It looks, it looks good. Is that too long or no? No.
The sides are supposed to be longer. It's like wispy. Do you like it?
I think I look like a dog mom now. Right? Like I'm a mother. Yeah.
Honey. What do you think? Hello? What do you think?
You go to the gym once and this.
Happens. Yes. I need attention. How well? What do we think?
Do we like mommy like this? Yeah.
Yeah. And my eyeballs.
Yeah. Is that annoying or no? No.
You get used to it. I'm just not seeing. I can't see. Anyway.
I need like LASIK anyway. So it just like compliments that right. Papa.
Looks really good. I like it. Thank you.
Can't wait to see the final results. This is it.
I thought you're going to do more. Do you say you want to cut it a little?
No. This is the final result. I like that.
I never said.
I never.
Said it. You like it? That's my baby.
I am a legit mom. Now take that Sam. My sister's going to be like,
you copied me. Hell yeah. I did. Hell yes I cut.
I copied it. I did. I did. I did. Oh my God. He's so cute.
A little booger bear guys. This is Falco the flirt. And you can follow him.
This is my baby child. Okay. Sorry.
You know, honestly,
I don't know why I didn't do this sooner in life time for friends reactions.
I forgot to turn on the mic for batches reaction.
So here it is.
Yeah. He said Beijing's well, anyways,
now that my mics back on stupid kind of love it.
I feel like I'm in the nineties or the eighties, the eighties.
I would like to just, uh, you out to dinner.
Why is a deep, beautiful hair? I'm sorry.
I have to watch my puppy.